vous allez découvrir l'île à tamazight
rio un groupe orléanais réunis autour
des textes de la chanteuse colette magny
au piano le jazzman orléanais vincent
viala et à la batterie
david georgelet auchan il a c'est moi
peut-être vous me reconnaissez à travers
ma voix est maintenant musique avec
colette magny et oui je suis la voix
d'arte et notre trio c'est aussi
l'engagement de chansons aujourd'hui le
spectre vocal de lylat à basit est large
en reprenant les chansons de colette
magny chanteuse engagée des années 60
s'est résolument vers l'engagement est
l'expression d'une colère que s'oriente
le trio orléanais
[Musique]
je pense que quand on fait répression
est quelque chose qui nous unique qui
nous lie encore plus dans dans tout dans
la revendication dans le fait de chanter
colette magny dans le fait d'aller
sortir des choses en nous dans cette
espèce de révolte que peut-être que
chacun d'entre nous a en soi
et cette liberté de joueurs
[Musique]
en partageant son émotion pour colette
magny la chine nous en laisse comme un
mot lilas tamasy à emmener dans son
aventure poétique et contestataire deux
musiciens de la scène jazz d'orléans
un trio d'amis un trio de jazz et un
trio de révolte et qui se connaissent
bien
là c'est quelqu'un qui a aussi qui est
sensible à ces causes la cause des
femmes
voilà je trouve que la pleinement sa
place pour pour emboîter le pas de
colette magny justement il a c'est parce
que je connais lilas et je sais que
quand ta chambre colette magny ya une
part de colette magny d'en chercher chez
lilas et ça pour nous en tant que
musicien accompagnateur
c'est très fort parce que on attend on
n'accompagne pas juste quelqu'un qui
reprendrait du colette magny sait on
accompagne quelqu'un qui vit du colette
magny que sans vous personne ne peut
rien du tout avant d'arriver à orléans
lille a agrandi en eure et loir dans une
famille venue d'algérie avec un père
ouvrier et des chants kabyles à la
maison à 50 ans révolus villa se forge à
travers colette magny un destin français
qui la réconcilie avec elle-même
chez nous on parlait pas politique moi
j'ai enfoui plein plein de choses
peut-être je sais pas peut-être que
c'est ça pourquoi je chante colette
magny peut-être que c'est ça au fond de
moi qui se passe c'est d'un seul coup en
janvier l'iran en vieillissant prenant
de l'âge ya des choses king qui peuvent
plus rester bloqué j'ai besoin de crier
ça j'ai besoin de le sortir
moi j'ai été élevé dans un an dans une
éducation
il fallait être discret allait pas se
faire trop remarquer et fallait sinon
voilà c'était un peu tabou de faire ça
c'était la honte de faire ça donc
et j'avais envie d'être chanteuse
comédienne depuis l'âge de 5 ans donc
vous imaginez cette espèce de paradoxes
de combat intérieur et aujourd'hui je
lui en ai marre j'en peux plus j'en ai
ar à la trompe
je suis un tout petit peu chez bmo de
sexe féminin
j'en ai gros sur le coeur
ras
tron
[Musique]
latron à travers les 14 titres de leur
album
la preuve est faite qu'une chanteuse
peut en cacher une autre près il
s'endort
moi j'en ai gros sur le coeur
[Musique]
à
ras